this is where so then the book comes
tell me 2018 yeah and from what I know I
haven't read the book okay what I know
of the book is that you
basically exposed a lot of people in the
book this is just what what I've heard
you
basically all the stuff you've been
doing you put in the book and while you
might not have said their names exactly
it was pretty easy for people to figure
out who they were
okay well I didn't expose anyone
um my book was like a 25 year old Memoir
basically and I didn't list all of these
sexapades so there were seven seven
people okay fake names
um
seven relationships like situationships
whatever you want to call them and what
I learned from that so there was a lot
of my book was about sharing my story
and being accountable the most like
salacious stories or sex they weren't
even in there because it wasn't a lot of
these guys it was a typical if you want
I'm sorry I said you could tell now if
you want yeah I mean I'm just kidding
yes I mean it's just kind of like that
was never my intention my book never had
ill intent now again I know the
salacious marketing was intentional
because I knew people were thinking I'm
gonna it's like it's like a thumbnail
yeah like yeah it's clickbait like yeah
look at all these guys in here yeah
because I know you're gonna [ __ ] buy
the book but when people actually read
it any person who's read my book is like
wait this is completely different than
how you pitched it and it really is a
book about accountability so
um those seven people really helped
we're by pivotal moments for me so again
I took what came with the salacious
marketing and again
misrepresenting myself is just that
right so you have to accept what comes
behind that so I wanted to sell a book I
had no problem with doing you know using
my tactics to just to get copies sold
and what came with that is she's not
trustworthy she's a [ __ ] and that's all
she cares about is money she's just a
quick money grab like she's the girl
that cannot be trusted and I understand
that if you've never read my book it's
like what I'm saying doesn't even make
sense it's like you would actually have
to physically read it that's why the
book is called judge this cover you're
gonna do that anyways there are people
that just took little Snippets from each
chapter
and judge me off of that you're talking
about
this guy I was talking about spitting in
his mouth or paying for flights that was
one that was circulating on Twitter I I
talked about how I paid for my own
flights so it's like I'm such a gold
digger why am I pay for my flights so
there's just things in there that I felt
like people did not want to understand
me you didn't open the book so your
opinion doesn't [ __ ] matter about the
book read it and then tell me how you
feel about me you know that's kind of
how I feel with that so so then you
write the book were any of the people
that were in the book mad that you wrote
the book
um the conversations I've had because
there's maybe like two or two guys in
there that I have not spoken to right
the other five I've had conversations
with since um one of the people I'd add
actually asked me to Market them as one
of the people in it they didn't mind
that
um other guys in my life just in general
were asked like why they weren't in it
they were like sad right
um but most of the guys I have a good
relationship with like we're still cool
so they understood that that was my
experience that was my perspective and
that was that I mean there was one
chapter I spoke to recently he um he was
like I was just waiting for you to say
my name so I could have sued you for
everything right and I'm just like well
that wasn't my plan like I wasn't trying
to hurt you but he was like I understood
your perspective and I get he said you
didn't you didn't lie in it so
okay so none of the guys had hurt
feelings over the book no okay okay well
so that that seems because I kind of
thought
um like from what I had heard is that
some of the guys maybe weren't happy
they were in the book I'm sure they
weren't but I think the people that
weren't happy about it the two that I'm
thinking of in my mind I just haven't
spoken to them okay you know the other
five I did so
you know okay I don't know I don't know
I don't know how they would feel so you
don't think like
because I'm just thinking this is I just
know how the guys are going to see it
like you're choosing to publicly link
with these people and maybe you didn't
want it to be public but it's like if
you're making a choice to go after the
Like Rappers athletes like that sort of
thing of course people are gonna call
you a hoe
and that's fine yeah and you know that's
the thing you don't shy away from that
yeah but it goes back to my original
question whether you think it's earned
or not
or it's like misrepresenting you or not
well I think there's that I have
misrepresented myself because again I
bundle of Britney is like her own that's
like
a Frankenstein I have created right and
that's like a fraction even just the
time we've spent the past few days
together probably very different than
what you've seen online you know so
that's what I have used to get views and
get clicks and I've realized that I
don't have to do that anymore so that's
where the misrepresentation comes in but
again a hoe and I guess is in this
sphere right is someone who has sex and
multiple guys okay well then that's not
a term I'm gonna shy away from I've had
sex with multiple guys now I'm not gonna
take that word and be like I'm So
Unworthy I'm a [ __ ] it just is what it
is like that's how they want to
distinguish what category women fall
under I got no problem with that that's
fine okay okay I've had sex multiple
guys didn't work out I moved on you know
okay so so that that part you don't
necessarily feel like was misrepresented
based on how the guys would see how they
would yeah how they would see it okay
okay so then next next this is this is
where I heard of you first okay let's
talk about PJ okay so you you do the
book is PJ next to is there something in
between
a meaning like when we met yeah
um yeah so we met
he he actually came to my hosting
um in 2018 May of 2018 so that's like
basically where we first met it was not
romantic like it literally had a job
there he's like hey I'm gonna come by
okay cool
um
I he invited me to his his game at UK
February 2019 right so we met
um I went back for my birthday so I went
to two Kentucky games and that's when we
first started talking like after my
birthday we talked almost every single
day and I was aware like he's younger
than me I always had a lot of judgment
towards guys who are younger than me
because I'm like you're younger than me
how can you handle me you know right
um but I always felt like PJ saw me for
me and that is the [ __ ] god to honest
truth
um
it makes me sad even thinking about it
because like
I don't know you just think people get
you and it just doesn't work out so
that's why I overlooked some of those
things like the age oh he's about to be
in the NBA I overlooked that because I
felt like oh my God I finally have a guy
who doesn't judge me who sees me for me
and like accepts it and understands my
value so I felt like he was somebody
that like deserved all my time and
attention and
you know it just didn't end up working
out long term so and how old was he when
it started how old were you because this
is the the next 20. I've got a million
questions about the age they get I'm so
glad you brought it out you grooming
like they they said because
what just to give context to the viewers
at home if you guys don't know anything
about Brittany I saw a video of you
where you were in the car saying this is
basically how to you can kind of get a
kid off of an NBA player yeah and it's
really easy because these guys don't
wear condoms and it's something to that
effect so then a couple years later when
you you as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible